on a nice cruise around country roads
in the jaguar xjl
it's the xj not the l that stands for
luxury explains our car man matus
the l stands for long version about 12
centimeters longer than the regular
jaguar xj
which is hardly on the short side itself
the jaguar xjl comes with a range of
three different engines
both gasoline and diesel we checked out
the 3 liter gas fueled engine with
250 kilowatts of power
the manufacturer's fuel rating of 9.6
liters per 100 kilometers is very tough
to achieve
the car's weight coupled with its high
torque engine take their toll on
efficiency
people normally associate the name
jaguar with classic sports cars like the
e-type
but mathis doesn't find the xjl that
sporty
weighing in at 1.8 tons however that's
understandable
if there's one thing the british are
good at says matas it's interior design
that's quality everywhere but never over
the top he has just the one concern
up front on the instrument panel where
the airbag would deploy
he's noticed an unsightly edge that
could have been done better
more on the interior later as for the
body
as expected the workmanship is excellent
the design is refreshingly modern
elegant but athletic looking
the extra wheelbase inches also
translate into a wider turning radius
increasing from 11.9 to 12.3 meters
around town especially in parking
garages that could mean some
awkward maneuvering
rear seat passengers will feel very
comfortable here
leather seats and ample leg room speak
for themselves
the back window has a sun visor that can
be activated
at the touch of a button there's even an
extra sunroof for rear passengers
the hand mounted blinds for the side
window seem almost prehistoric in
comparison
and instead of a monitor with tv
reception all we have when you
click down these overhead panels are
mirrors although at least with lighting
my absolute decisions the absolute
highlight among the extras is the dual
view display for the infotainment system
when he pushes this button a little
window pops up on the map
closing it produces a video but mata
still has the map in front
another nice feature even if not as
unusual
is the piano black trim on the
instrument panel
there's also a range of delightful
details such as the
analog clock adding a touch of glass to
the front cabin
there's an increasing trend towards
fully digital instrument clusters
they allow for greater design
flexibility and a wider range of data
displays
what bothers mathis however is that the
display is not
100 smooth if he steps on it and the
revs shoot up
the needle shutters the same is true
when you slow down
but what about the bigger picture
with a final price tag far in excess of
100 000 euros as
in this case the jaguar xjl doesn't come
cheap
but looking at the competition for
mercedes porsche bmw or audi
they're in roughly the same price
bracket if you're looking for a car that
stands out from the crowd however
and the xjl might be the right choice
done is the xjlvillite directive
alternative